the fast turn of recent events in Turkey
from July's failed coup and subsequent
mass arrests to military action in Syria
against Islamic state and Kurds has
prompted some support from MEP s but
plenty more concerned members of
Parliament's Foreign Affairs Committee
were meeting following a fact-finding
mission to Turkey last week 15 July was
a coup against Turkish democracy I think
it's aftermath and how the government
deals with it will be a crucial test for
democracy in Turkey and we don't know
the outcome thousands of military
personnel judges academics activists and
journalists are still in detention some
may face death if president read ship
aired one reintroduces the death penalty
as he is threatened we are totally
against the penalty this is the red line
it's important for us to accept on top
of it all alarm bells at turkeys
rapprochement with Russia the gans
rapprochement with President Putin
should be a great worry and concern too
as all as I dare say these two strong
men have a very similar mentality in
Syria turkey too has a red line beyond
attacking is to stop Syrian Kurds
advancing west of the river Euphrates
towards its border one thing everyone
agrees on the --use deal with Turkey to
stem the flow of refugees at the Turkish
end with more migrant flows expected no
one's arguing over that right now